une très bonne rentrée pour une session
budgétaire qui s'annonce à nouveau bien
chargé et il n'y aura pas que du
budgétaire dans les textes que nous
allons examiner même avant le pdfss
alors nous entendons ce matin madame
Patricia Ferrand présidente et Monsieur
Jean eu Tesson vice-président de ludique
sur le projet de loi portant mesures
d'urgence relative au fonctionnement du
marché du travail en vue du plein emploi
et les rapporteurs étaient dessinés
donc alors sous réserve de sa bonne
transmission par l'Assemblée nationale
nous devrions examiner ce texte en
commission le 12 octobre prochain puis
en séance publique à partir du 25
octobre nous rapporteurs pressentis que
je soumettrai à votre confirmation tout
à l'heure son Frédéric puissat et
Olivier Hainaut j'indique cette audition
fait l'objet d'une captation vidéo qui
sera retransmise en direct sur le site
du Sénat est disponible en à la demande
et je passe tout de suite la parole à
Madame Ferrand
merci Madame le Présidente Mesdames
alors pardon il faut que je
voilà
merci merci et bonjour bonjour à toutes
et tous
alors j'ai pas appris on n'a pas prévu
en fait de propos liminaires en tout cas
on vous remercie pour pour votre
invitation on n'a pas véritablement
prévu de propos liminaire sur ce projet
de loi qui est assez
restreint au nombre d'articles voilà qui
qui touche qui touche pour deux articles
à la question de l'assurance chômage
peut-être une petite précaution vous
savez que lunédique est un organisme est
un organisme paritaire donc j'en suis je
suis présidente du conseil
d'administration représentant la CFDT
représentant de la CFDT j'ai été sans
représentants du Medef
je prends une toute petite précaution
parce que sur ce projet de loi
comment dire les organisations n'auront
pas forcément le même point de vue donc
vous les auditionnerez certainement par
collège et elle apporteront leur point
de vue tout à fait direct ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'on n'a pas des choses
intéressantes à dire je vous rassure
mais voilà on aura peut-être un regard
paritaire un peu un peu décalé j'ai
envie de dire plutôt voilà
dans le dans votre question voilà je
prendrai cette précaution là de bien
préciser que c'est un regard c'est un
regard paritaire voilà c'est simplement
une une précaution vous connaissez sans
doute notre voilà nos fonctionnements
mais évidemment
nous ne sommes pas les les portes
paroles des organisations et je pense
que c'est important de pouvoir parler
de lunédique de sa situation et de la
façon aussi dans le projet de loi peut
bousculer son fonctionnement voilà
si vous n'aviez pas prévu de propos
liminaires je peut-être passer tout de
suite la parole à nos rapporteurs
pressentis
Frédéric puissa olivierno qui ont
sûrement eu beaucoup de questions à vous
poser donc ce sera vraiment un échange
plutôt que
merci madame la Présidente donc
nous espérons déjà avec Olivier que vous
allez voter pour nous pour que nous
soyons pressenti sur ce texte de loi
parce que nous avons déjà commencé un
certain nombre d'auditions en la matière
merci madame la Présidente et merci
Monsieur le vice-président de votre
présence nous avons aujourd'hui
effectivement deux auditions
d'importantes la vôtre et celle des
ministres cet après-midi simplement déjà
parce que toute promesse politique tenue
doit être saluée saluer la promesse
politique du gouvernement de faire des
textes courts puisque effectivement nous
avons cinq articles dans ce texte de loi
et dans ces cinq articles seulement deux
concerne l'assurance chômage et un sur
la VAE dont on parlera tout à l'heure
Olivier sans doute mais bon en toute
état de cause ce texte de loi pose un
certain nombre de questions
d'abord la première c'est véritablement
la gouvernance de l'assurance chômage
aujourd'hui l'assurance chômage est
gérée sous format paritarisme vous
l'avez dit madame la Présidente vous
représentez ce pariarisme presque à vous
deux dans vos dans vos vos historiques
et les représentants soient os ou aux
pieds que vous pouvez représenter ce
texte de loi au-delà du fait qu'il
permet effectivement de poursuivre la
réforme de 2019 le décret de carence de
précise et c'est une vraie question de
fond que le gouvernement se ressaisit du
dispositif de l'assurance chômage
jusqu'à décembre 2023 donc en gros je le
fais un peu court il reprend un peu les
clés du camion considérons peut-être
peut-être c'est peut-être parce que vont
nous dire les mini cet après-midi que
les partenaires sociaux n'ont pas
suffisamment bien géré ludique pour
effectivement
l'instant présent et pour l'avenir donc
la vraie question et je la pose j'allais
dire aux deux composantes que vous
représentez est-ce que vous considérez
que l'assurance chômage doit rester dans
le champ du paritarisme et est-ce que ça
fonctionne première question deuxième
question en ce qui concerne
effectivement le budget de l'assurance
chômage
euh j'ai écouté hier le ministre je
pense qu'il qu'il nous tiendra peut-être
des propos similaires cet après-midi
en clair il annoncé effectivement des
excédents sur le budget 2022 de
l'assurance chômage alors de façon
j'allais dire très politique qui
considéré que la loi 2018 avait permis
ses excédents il me semble quand même
que quand je regarde à la fois
l'historique des budgets de l'assurance
chômage qui était en excédent en 2008
qui ont été effectivement déficites par
le passé mais que vous annonciez avant
la réforme de 2019 un retour à
l'équilibre du système d'assurance
chômage est-ce que vous pouvez nous
confirmer que nonobstant le décret de
carence de 2019 on aurait effectivement
un retour à l'équilibre des contes de
l'inédits donc ça c'est la deuxième
question et toujours dans les contes de
l'inédit vous aviez fait un exercice
assez intéressant à l'époque et
d'ailleurs c'est presque dommage que
vous l'ayez pas fait un peu plus tôt
vous aviez détaillé la dette de
l'assurance chômage et finalement la
provenance de la dette de l'assurance
chômage et entre autres vous aviez
pointé un certain grand nombre de
domaines qui relevaient plutôt de la
compétence de l'État en tout cas de
décision de l'État le point de retraite
complémentaire des chômeurs qui pèse 2
milliards d'euros dans le budget de
lunédique l'indemnisation des
travailleurs frontaliers
transfrontaliers qui pèse à peu près 700
millions d'euros dans le compte de
l'inédith le fonctionnement de Pôle
Emploi qui pèse 4 milliards d'euros dans
le camp du nethic et l'activité
partielle qui a beaucoup pesé notamment
au cours de la crise sanitaire est-ce
que vous pensez qu'à date toujours dans
la partie budgétaire on peut pardon du
terme nettoyer le budget de l'inédith
pour rendre à l'état ce qui lui
appartient et que vous effectivement
vous ressentiez sur les dispositifs liés
à l'assurance chômage et à ce système
assurantiel et enfin la dernière
question sur le bonus malus alors c'est
là où on va peut-être avoir un avis qui
sera un peu divergent selon votre votre
position de façon constante la majorité
du Sénat c'est pas le cas de tous les
sénateurs ont été opposés au bonus malus
deux approches possibles sur ce texte de
loi qui je le rappelle quand même ne
remet pas en cause le bonus palu sur le
texte de loi il dit simplement il faut
éclair entre guillemets les entreprises
qui sont aujourd'hui frappées par le
bonus malus en leur permettant d'avoir
la liste des personnes qui sont
concernées par les contrats courts donc
c'est ce que dit ce texte de loi là mais
à partir de là il y a deux approches
possibles soit on continue à être reposé
au bonus malus et quand il s'appliquer
soit on peut éventuellement entre
guillemets nettoyer là aussi le bonus
malus c'est considérer que son malusier
les entreprises qui vraiment font des
contrats et du coup évacuer de la partie
malus par exemple les intérimaires qui
sont quand même des gens qui sont
intéressants quand l'activité fluctue
par exemple les licenciements
économiques qui comptent aujourd'hui
dans le dans le malus par exemple tout
ce qui peut être abandon de poste qui
compte aujourd'hui dans le malus donc
quel est votre approche sur le bonus
malus est-ce qu'on continue à dire on
est pour on est contre et puis la vie
continue telle qu'elle est ou est-ce
qu'on peut dire effectivement on a un
dispositif qu'on peut éventuellement
affiner pour qu'il colle au mieux à la
réalité du terrain qui font qu'à un
moment donné effectivement personne ne
peut se satisfaire des contrats courts
voilà peut-être sur les trois questions
très bien je vous laisse répondre aux
questions de Frédéric puissa il y a déjà
beaucoup de questions et ensuite Olivier
nous prendra le relais très bien merci
merci beaucoup des questions
des questions majeures trois questions
tout à fait majeures à laquelle bien sûr
on répondra en répondra à deux voix
alors sur la question de la gouvernance
de l'assurance chômage est-ce que ça
fonctionne alors je me permettrai je
vais dire oui je vais dire oui
évidemment non je me permettrai de
souligner que
dans sous le vocable gouvernance en fait
il y a deux axes qu'il faut qu'il faut
pouvoir bien
identifier me semble-t-il tout d'abord
il y a
il y a la le fait que
avant ce projet de loi et encore à ce
jour
la loi délègue au partenaires sociaux la
négociation des règles de la science
chômage voilà et vous l'avez bien
précisé ce projet de loi a pour but
notamment de mettre totalement entre
parenthèses c'est
cette délégation c'est un acte
effectivement très fort
voilà donc il y a ce premier il y a ce
premier axe et il y a le deuxième axe
j'ai envie de dire qui est celui de la
gestion du régime lui-même qui revient à
l'unédique qui est au service des
partenaires sociaux à la fois pour
mettre en oeuvre les les règles qu'il
décide par accord
hors régime de carence et et gérer le
régime financièrement suivre
l'application des règles est-ce qu'elle
correspondait à des objectifs comment on
évalue pour nourrir la prochaine
négociation etc etc donc
j'ai j'ai envie de dire si on parle de
la gestion
moi je pense que notamment la dernière
période pendant la crise covid a
véritablement montré que l'inédit qui
était présente savait gérée quand on
Mars 2017 pardon 2020
l'ensemble de l'économie et vous avez
été tous comme tout le monde frappé par
ça à lunédique en quelques en quelques
semaines on a eu un million de chômeurs
en plus un démilisés et
financièrement fallait trouver les
financements etc le système a fonctionné
on a assuré il n'y a pas eu de
difficultés de versement des allocations
etc voilà donc je pense que au contraire
ça valorise
le fait qu'on ait eu cette expertise
cette ancienneté un fonctionnement
extrêmement fluide le fait que les
investisseurs nous connaissaient etc
a prouver que l'unédicte c'est une
structure paritaire associative qui qui
fonctionne bien voilà après je pense pas
qu'il faille aujourd'hui
qualifier le le
simplement le fonctionnement de
l'unédique par rapport notamment ce que
certains
voudraient faire rapidement par rapport
au niveau de l'endettement d'abord c'est
pas le lieu qu'il choisit voilà
et y compris en régime de Clarence
l'endettement a augmenté voilà donc je
ferai cette distinction là sur la
question de la gouvernance mais vous
avez totalement raison sur le fait que
c'est un acte très fort qui est qui est
marqué dans dans ce projet de loi
justifier par le gouvernement
d'une part
par la par l'urgence pour la
prolongation la prolongation des règles
dans la mesure où aucun document de
cadrage n'a été envoyé quelques mois
auparavant ce qui tombait pendant la
présidentielle etc etc donc un conseil
politique ok mais
qui est en théorie aurait pu fonctionner
mais on sait bien que tout n'est pas que
de théorie et et
donc pour proroger pour proroger ses
règles
il reprend la main il reprend la main
pas pour 4 mois il reprend la main pour
quasiment voilà un peu plus d'un an voir
avec le bonus malus un an et demi
puisque en fait on est en plus à double
détente
voilà moi je commenterai pas plus je
vais laisser mais mais voilà comment je
qualifierais la question gouvernance qui
est posée qui est posée aujourd'hui j'ai
envie
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateur bonjour
je vais comme l'a dit Patricia je vais
je vais venir vous m'exprimer avec un
spectre prisme différent forcément
simplement un mot sur le projet de loi
il y a deux façons de le voir soit se
dire c'est très politique soit c'est
seulement technique alors pourquoi ça
pourrait être que technique tout
simplement parce que nous attendions
pour le 30 juin une lettre de cadrage
quand je dis nous ce sont les
partenaires sociaux et pas lunédique
puisque ce sont les partenaires sociaux
qui négocient les règles d'assurance
chômage je me permets d'insister parce
que c'est pour nous c'est vraiment
important de ne pas mélanger les deux
il y a eu les élections
on n'a pas vu de l'aide de cadrage et le
temps passé puisque l'échéance des
règles en cours
aurait conduit si on avait reçu une
lettre de cadrage après l'été à de la
précipitation ce dont nous ne voulions
pas
on a pour le coup travaillé en
concertation avec l'État pour savoir
comment sortir de cette situation là il
y avait probablement la prorogation des
règles actuelles mais avec
quels outils il était possible de le
faire un simple décret peut-être était
dangereux et donc il fallait en passer
par la loi ça c'était la conclusion du
ministère
et techniquement il fallait suspendre la
gouvernance de l'assurance chômage en
tout cas le rôle des partenaires sociaux
pendant un certain temps c'est pour ça
que si c'est simplement une suspension
technique on peut dire que le projet de
loi en si nous concerne et technique
mais
quelles sont les intentions qu'il y a
derrière et ce que j'ai on a déjà eu
l'occasion d'en parler avec le ministre
mais aussi avec d'autres parlementaires
est-ce que sa préfigure la gouvernance
que l'État veut pour l'assurance chômage
c'est-à-dire suspendre
le rôle des partenaires sociaux dans
l'élaboration des règles j'ai pas la
réponse je pense que c'est l'avenir qui
nous dira quels étaient les intentions
initiales mais comme je suis d'un
naturel optimiste je préfère m'en tenir
à
un dispositif purement technique et dans
la concertation qui s'annonce quand tout
à con nous annonce on verra on verra ce
qu'il en est
en tout cas je voudrais saluer le rôle
des partenaires sociaux dans dans le
passé dans toutes ces années dans
lesquelles ils ont élaboré eux-mêmes
entre eux les règles d'assurance chômage
mais on peut dire que on est loin de
connaître un échec et si on veut trouver
des raisons c'est pas l'échec du
paritarisme qu'il faut considérer
et s'agissant de la gouvernance
maintenant
je pense que il est bon de travailler
sur la gouvernance parce que l'unédique
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas l'unique d'hier
ne serait-ce que par
son rôle de financeur
je vais juste donner une image
j'ai été pendant 10 ans jusqu'à il y a
pas longtemps président de l'URSSAF
caisse nationale où là les montants de
recouvrement sont très importants près
de 600 milliards c'est très fléché on
sait quand on donne de l'argent à
l'assurance maladie on sait d'où vient
cet argent précisément à l'euro près
quand on verse aux communes pour le
versement transport on sait d'où ça
vient les cotisations sont directement
fléchées vers leur destinataire et à
l'unédique on est arrivé à exactement
l'inverse c'est-à-dire que l'unédique
est devenu une sorte de pot commun
alimenté par des cotisations patronales
et maintenant de la CSG
et puis on nous fait financer avec cette
somme d'argent
ce qui est le coeur du métier de
l'assurance chômage au départ c'est à
dire les allocations mais aussi enfin
des agressions des demandeurs d'emploi
mais aussi maintenant la retraite des
des mêmes demandeurs d'emploi les
prisonniers et puis le financement Pôle
Emploi
le financement de Pôle emploi et notre
opérateur
pour une partie de son activité mais
c'est nous qui finançons la quasi enfin
la plus grosse partie du budget de Pôle
Emploi donc il y a quelque chose qui
n'est plus lisible dans le fléchage de
ces sommes qui restent très importantes
et si c'est pas lisible c'est difficile
de il faut il faut me rendre en tout cas
lisible la gouvernance et c'est ça la
vraie question et on va pas vous dire
aujourd'hui qu'il faut que la
gouvernance évolue de telle ou telle
façon simplement soit on change les
missions et les financements
soit on modifie aussi la gouvernance en
conséquence soit on soit on modifie la
gouvernance donc voilà ce que je voulais
vous apporter comme élément de réponse
pour l'instant
je partage tout à fait ce point de vue à
noter d'ailleurs que dans le sopher de
ma part dans l'exposé des motifs il est
fait
référence à une consortation non
seulement sur la modulation en fonction
de la modulation des allocations en
fonction de la conjoncture mais aussi
sur la gouvernance et
comme le dit jean-eud
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
alors là pour le coup l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales et patronales
sont d'accord pour dire que on est un
peu au milieu du gué que
la loi de 2018 à
ouvert une période qui aurait pu
fonctionner j'ai envie de le dire mais
qui je vais le dire comme ça là je donne
un tout petit peu mon sentiment mais les
organisations je porte là pour le coup
un peu la voix dans l'ensemble des
organisations elles sont assez d'accord
pour pour dire que le document de
cadrage de 2019 était un document de
cadrage qui rendait la négociation
impossible et et donc on est au milieu
du guet et la volonté des organisations
aujourd'hui c'est bien de clarifier les
responsabilités des uns et des autres
très clairement et que
le statu quo n'est pas vraiment possible
voilà et qui doit y avoir une évolution
donc je pense que elle n'est elle n'est
portée cette
cet accord collectif n'est porté dans le
dans le queue dans l'exposé du d'exposer
des motifs du projet de loi je pense
qu'il est partagé par l'ensemble des
organisations la façon dont il va
s'organiser ça on a encore aucune
visibilité
peut-être sur le le deuxième la deuxième
question puisque jean-eud a commencé à
l'aborder et de manière tout à fait
pertinente parce que c'est bien le c'est
bien le sujet à quels sont les
compétences de l'État qu'elles sont les
responsabilités des partenaires sociaux
et dans ce dans ce détail en fait
de notamment de la composition de la
dette une fine
en tout cas de
la composition des dépenses de lunédique
aussi
c'est vrai qu'on a mis en évidence
depuis quelques années et les ordres de
grandeur en poids relatifs n'ont pas
n'ont pas véritablement
évolué sauf évidemment la part de
l'activité partielle puisque pendant la
grise covid l'unedicat financée un tiers
d'activité partielle ce qui signifie sur
les deux années environ 15 milliards
d'euros à la fois du fait des dépenses
directes d'allocations d'activité
partielle et 30% et à la fois par manque
de recettes puisqu'il n'y a pas de
cotisation des
c'est à peu près 4 milliards 11 et 4
milliards 15 milliards d'euros en ordre
de grandeur
du coût de l'activité partielle donc
dans la dette l'ensemble des mesures
d'urgence dans la dette de lunédique qui
va
sans doute s'élever autour de je donne
des ordres de grandeur je suis pas très
précise mais au de toute façon milliards
d'euros
en 60 milliards d'euros on a en 18 19
milliards d'euros qui relèvent des
strictes mesures d'urgence
qui ont été financés pendant la période
covid activité partielle 15 milliards et
ensuite prolongation des droits et
années blanche intermittent c'est
environ 18 milliards d'euros donc on met
aussi en évidence dans nos nouvelles
publications vous verrez on met en
évidence cette dette covid que nous
portons que mais que pour nous nous
estimons qu'elle ne relève pas du
financement du régime ceci dit nous
avons évidemment
le régime a fonctionné en période de
base conjoncture le régime a fonctionné
pour payer les allocations des des
personne indemnisées qui sont arrivés en
nombre dans le régime sur les
sur ce que vous aviez
identifié comme les frontaliers le
fonctionnement de Pôle Emploi etc etc
c'est aujourd'hui
toujours voilà on a toujours à peu près
les mêmes les mêmes points relatifs
c'est toujours sont toujours des
interrogations j'en veux de la cité les
nouveaux bénéficiaires
que sont les détenus
y compris les indépendants il y a eu
beaucoup de de
d'interrogations puisqu'ils ne cotise
pas donc ça ça pose un certain nombre de
questions dans un régime qu'on souhaite
nous toujours assurantiel
ce qui cotise ont des droits et et voilà
on a une frontière une frontière qui
aujourd'hui un site les organisations à
à
vouloir une clarification des
responsabilités avec avec l'État j'ai
envie de vous voulez peut-être ajouter
donc sur cette dette
dite covid
nous ne parlons plus de enfin nous
faisons toujours désormais la séparation
entre la dette
structurelle de l'unédique ou
conjoncturelle plutôt
enfin lié à sa mission et cette dette
exceptionnelle qui vient je voudrais le
compléter ce qu'a dit Patricia qui est
né de mesure auxquelles on n'a pas été
associé enfin en tout cas la décision
desquelles nous n'avons pas été associés
parce que ça il y a eu quand même
lui dit qui a travaillé avec les
services de l'État à l'époque mais
on peut se demander si comme la dette de
la sécurité sociale née du covid il faut
pas la transférer alors la cadette
existe je suis pas en train de dire
qu'il faut transférer la dette covid de
ludique à la CAD c'est pas du tout ça
non non non mais simplement dans peu
importe d'ailleurs pour nous c'est pas à
nous de dire qui doit la reprendre
simplement on considère que nous ne
faisons que du portage
et nous pensons bien engagés les
discussions avec l'État pour savoir qui
va devoir la rembourser en attendant on
rembourse notre propre dette
heureusement grâce aux excédents alors
je sais pas si on en parle maintenant
vous vouliez peut-être en reparler après
de des excédents
alors les excédents dont on parle ne
sont que des prévisions puisque
l'exercice 2022 n'est pas clos
en revanche tous les quadrimestres
ludique publie des prévisions les
commandes et les dernières prévisions
connues font apparaître un excédent
prévisible pour 2022 de 2 milliards 5
en tout cas à peu près 10 milliards sur
les 20223 24 et on a eu l'occasion d'en
parler dans le couloir nous nous
refusons même si techniquement c'est
bien un excédent à parler d'excédent
nous serons en excédent lorsque notre
dette sera négative pour l'instant on
est en dette
abyssale en regard de nos ressources et
des résultats d'exploitation qu'on peut
faire chaque année mais en fait le mot
excédent laisse entendre qui aura une
cagnotte etc et que quelqu'un pourra la
prendre en tout cas
j'insiste le vrai excédent c'est celui
de notre dette et on y est pas alors en
attendant
c'est quand même à noter on génère des
excédents malgré tout ce dont patricia a
parlé c'est à dire des charges qui ne
sont pas les nôtres à l'origine et qu'on
doit financer
j'ai pas insisté mais en réalité si on
enlevait
ce qui n'est pas propre à notre mission
ou si ce qui n'est pas des charges qui
ne sont pas qui n'ont pas comme
contrepartie des cotisations plutôt
c'est comme ça qu'on doit le voir
les finances de ludique seraient
nettement différentes
on se poserait d'autres questions sans
doute mais ça serait différent donc
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
complément de des propos de Patricia
elle alors peut-être la troisième
question en attendant en attendant les
autres concernant
concernant le bonus malus donc l'article
sur le bonus malus
donc
qui informe effectivement qui est clair
les entreprises avec les données
nominatives des personnes
des personnes qui qui expliquent
le bonus ou le malus
qui
est appliquée à l'entreprise
[Musique]
avant de
je ne sais pas s'il faut nettoyer ou pas
nettoyer moi j'ai
un petit sujet qui là je vais en parler
au nom des organisations syndicales
quand même un tout petit point d'alerte
parce que c'est pratique on les a vu
dans d'autres pays je sais que on aime
bien faire du benchmark sur plein de
sujets notamment de l'indemnisation mais
pour le coup là sur le bonus malus ça
serait on peut aussi en faire d'avoir
les données nominatives
pour les entreprises ça peut présenter
un risque et peut-être peut-être moi
j'ai pas la solution mais est-ce que il
ne pourrait pas y avoir
la possibilité de de
sécuriser un peu les personnes parce que
qu'est-ce qui risque de se passer dans
un certain nombre de cas l'avoir vu sur
le terrain
c'est qu'il peut y avoir un espèce de
chantage à l'emploi la plupart des
personnes qui sont Inde la moitié des
personnes qui sentent indemnisées sont
indemnisés sur des sur des contrats
courts et récurrents et travail en fait
travail tous les mois la plupart chez le
même employeur
c'est ce qu'on appelle la raie embauche
elles sont réembauchées sur des contrats
courts sur le même employeur je parle
pas de 20% des contrats je parle de 75%
de l'ensemble des contrats donc c'est
c'est vraiment c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement massif donc
aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un risque alors
je le dis aussi
enfin comment dire de manière
extrêmement posée parce que voilà ça
existe est-ce qu'il y a un risque de
Chantal à l'emploi et de nombreux cours
au droit je t'aurais embauche pas si si
tu t'inscris à Pôle emploi et tu touches
des allocs première question ou alors de
de travail au noir donc
c'est pas ça sera pas nécessairement
très massif c'est un risque et je pense
en tout cas du point de vue des
organisations syndicales il y a un sujet
autour de comment est-ce qu'on peut
sécuriser un petit peu
ces éléments là qui ne sont pas pris en
compte nécessairement
dans la réflexion aujourd'hui
on comprend bien l'objectif de vouloir
être dans la transparence de vouloir les
entreprises puissent contrôler en fait
puissent contrôler
le calcul de la cotisation et de la
surcotisation qui est appliquée ceci dit
ça risque d'impliquer des pratiques sur
le terrain qu'il faut peut-être pouvoir
encadrer voilà ça c'est un vrai sujet
qui est partagé par les os je ne sais
pas par les opérer mais mais quand même
un peu peut-être voilà merci Patricia
je me porterai pas de jugement sur le
dispositif lui-même bonus malus en tant
que vice-président de ludique je suis
pas là pour le faire je peux simplement
vous apporter un témoignage de chef
d'entreprise qui est concerné à
subjectif puisque on est dans un des 7
secteurs pendant 30 ans jusqu'à il y a
pas longtemps je présidais la Fédération
du transport et de la logistique sous
température dirigée activité qui par
nature
sont très saisonnières saisonnières à
cause du climat mais saisonnières aussi
à cause des fêtes enfin les mois de
décembre c'est le si monstrueux et puis
dans mon dans mon groupe j'ai une
activité de logistique des vins et
spiritueux activités très saisonnière
aussi
on sait pas comment améliorer notre taux
de séparation et pour l'améliorer il y a
deux solutions soit on demande par
exemple à nos sociétés d'intérim dont on
ne peut pas se passer compte tenu de ce
que je vous ai dit de nous envoyer
seulement leur propre salarié auquel cas
on n'a pas de taux de séparation
ou bien de privilégier ceux qui vont
trouver une mission juste après nous
alors ils peuvent nous dire ben écoutez
on veut bien mais vous payez plus cher
et dans un contexte de recherche de
préservation de marge notamment à cause
de l'énergie c'est pas simple
ou alors on s'organise différemment on
met on investit on stocke du travail
pour étaler nos besoins de main d'oeuvre
mais
ça nécessite beaucoup d'énergie et je
prends l'exemple de notre société de
logistique des mains spiritueux
on est on a un taux dans le secteur
transport et
entreposage aux alentours de 85%. donc
en dessous maintenant du seuil des 150
donc en fait on se demande pourquoi on
est encore concerné et puis ma société
je vais vous faire peur on est à 775
pour cent
si on veut progresser c'est à dire
baisser notre malus parce que on est
forcément à au malus maximum
on va jamais on va on va faire des
efforts mais on restera toujours au
malus maximum on va pas pouvoir
progresser donc qu'est-ce qu'on se dit
bah on fait aucun effort on change rien
puisque toute façon on va payer et c'est
contraire à l'esprit du dispositif et je
ne remets pas en cause pour ça le
dispositif simplement je vous apporte un
élément de enfin témoignage de ce que
nous vivons et si je vais plus loin pour
répondre à l'identification des salariés
si j'étais
[Musique]
méchant
j'irai voir mon URSSAF et je lui dirai
donnez-nous la liste des salariés et je
lui dirai surtout bah on n'est pas
d'accord avec cette liste un tel
n'aurait pas dû être dans la liste
alors quel est mon cours est-ce que je
vais aller en commission de recours à
miamiable URSSAF ça c'est la loi
normalement
conduit à cela mais qu'est-ce qu'elle va
faire la commission de recours à miam
face à ça elle va se référer peut-être
au service ça sera à mon avis ça sera
stérile ou alors je dis bah tiens un tel
j'aimerais bien avoir plus de détails et
que vous m'expliquez pourquoi il est
dans la liste et auquel cas on se
retrouve avec une confidentialité remise
en cause sur le parcours du salarié en
question et du coup moi je ne sais pas
comment on peut s'en sortir de ça c'est
une vraie problématique qui n'a pas été
intégrée quand le dispositif a été mis
en place sur le recours amiable quand
j'étais à l'URSSAF j'avais attiré
l'attention sur ça mais c'est pas
vraiment tranché simplement la réponse
ça a été de dire on vous donne la liste
des salariés
mais oui mais comment la vérifier voilà
et peut-être juste
pour le compte des partenaires sociaux
au Père des évaluations bien évidemment
et ce dispositif sera évalué ceci dit il
n'est appliqué que depuis quelques jours
et que nous n'avons pas encore les
données consolidées et certaines donc à
ce jour on ne peut pas
lunédique n'est pas en mesure de de
proposer des premiers éléments
d'évaluation
mais
ce que ce que j'en veux
malgré tout avec des quelques premiers
chiffres qui ne sont pas consolidés
encore une fois je prends beaucoup
beaucoup de précautions
la situation que jean-eud a décrite avec
avec son entreprise
semblerait semblerait est une situation
pas si unique que ça avec une très très
forte dispersion dans les secteurs des
entreprises à malus et des entreprises à
bonus éloignées
du niveau médian et donc avec une
incitation mais encore une fois je
prends beaucoup de précautions avec une
incitation qu'il faudra enfin le
mécanisme d'incitation il faudra
l'évaluer parce que comme le dit
jean-eud malgré tous nos efforts je n'y
arrivera pas à
envie on y arrivera pas nécessairement
donc voilà je encore une fois
quelques chiffres sont sortis pour voilà
pour pour me dire
aujourd'hui il est impliqué alors quand
même à un nombre extrêmement faible
d'entreprise dit en faisant le commun
parce que voilà
et et sur quelques secteurs dont
certains ont été exclus avec la crise
covid voilà donc évaluer ce dispositif
aujourd'hui
et d'abord faudrait avoir des données
c'est assez compliqué et
il y a quand même des interrogations
autour du mécanisme incitatif est-ce
qu'il fonctionnerait bien ou pas c'est
vraiment une des questions évaluatives
qu'on regardera
un petit complément madame vous avez
évoqué l'idée d'exclure l'intérim
non c'est pas vous c'est vous oui en
fait il y a une autre situation qui
pourrait être exclu c'est le cas du
salarié
à qui on propose un CDI qui le refuse et
qui se retrouve en
séparation alors qu'on lui proposait
autre chose et pour l'employeur
se retrouver pénalisé parce que son
salarié refusait le CDI qui avait
peut-être avec d'excellentes raisons
qu'on lui proposait
[Musique]
ça incite pas beaucoup à faire des
efforts
alors là vous comprendrez que je vais
intervenir
je ne dis pas que ça n'existe pas mais
tout comme les abandonne poste c'est des
choses qui ne sont pas vraiment pesées
je pense que beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprises peuvent le connaître y
compris en ce moment je rappelle quand
même que la modification des règles à
très très fortement baissé les droits de
ceux qui de ceux qui qui alternent
entre emploi et
emploi et période d'inactivité et que y
compris juridiquement c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement
difficile difficile à qualifier et
autant on peut
je pense que c'est extrêmement important
d'entendre les réalités de terrain et de
voir de voir
d'entendre des cas ou certains chefs
d'entreprise peuvent se trouver des
emparés on a aussi beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de salariés
qui aujourd'hui se voit proposer des
contrats de quelques heures
y compris y compris en période de
difficulté de recrutement je le le les
missions d'intérim InCar sont de moins
d'un jour et donc voilà on parle de
20-21 millions de missions par an enfin
voilà donc tout ça pour dire que
c'est pas du tout du tout évident de de
de
d'évaluer les comportements mais au
départ même si on rencontre des des
situations de terrain extrêmement
compliquées et je veux bien l'entendre
de la part des chefs d'entreprise ça
reste un contrat le contrat de travail
ça reste un engagement des parties et et
pour le coup
le il faut pouvoir peser et documenter
tout ça voilà ça sera et c'est vrai que
l'inédit
nous on essaye collectivement d'avoir
à l'une et dix au sein d'une éthique des
expertises et des questions évaluatives
justement pour nourrir les partenaires
sociaux dans dans ce type de réflexion
et et dont le débat public en général on
peut dire qu'à une édit qu'on essaye
d'être intelligent
la conclusion la première partie alors
je vais passer la parole à Olivier nous
et puis ensuite nous avons cinq cinq
collègues qui sont inscrits donc il
faudra un peu un peu condenser les
6 collègues il faudra un peu être concis
dans les réponses des armées Olivier
Hainaut oui merci madame la présidente
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
vice-président d'abord merci d'avoir
ramassé les enjeux de la négociation et
et de la gestion et d'avoir situé ce
projet de loi qui a une dimension comme
le l'avait dit technique politique et
financière encore qu'on est quand même
toujours rattrapé par la politique
c'est Pierre Mauroy qui disait ça je
suis nordiste donc je me souviens de ce
qu'il disait toujours ça
d'abord sur le sur le paritarisme
je salue vos propos parce que voyez-vous
on a quelques fois l'impression
lorsqu'on est attaché au paritarisme
mais ce qu'on appelle le modèle drainant
d'être plus royaliste que le roi et donc
je pense qu'il est bon que les
partenaires sociaux
réaffirment leur attachement au
paritarisme et que le paritarisme est
bien peut faire en sorte que il doit
faire en sorte d'ailleurs que une
négociation puisse aboutir sur le plan
financier on a effectivement besoin de
de bilan et d'évaluation parce qu'on a
peu un peu l'impression qu'on passe
d'une convention à une autre sans avoir
totalement mesuré les impacts de la
convention précédente et de ce point de
vue quand même quelques questions
notamment sur l'activité
partielle sur le dispositif d'activité
partielle qu'en pensez-vous bon il y a
bien évidemment eu celui de mars 2020 et
celui de juin 2020 au global est-ce que
vous vous pensez que il est nécessaire
de le faire évoluer ou est-ce qu'ils
vont penser que ça fonctionne quels sont
les impacts financiers de cette activité
partielle bon vous avez peut-être mais
c'est pas spécifiquement votre sujet à
un avis sur la VAE donc là aussi je
serai heureux de vous entendre et puis
dernier mot sur la question de la de la
gouvernance est-ce que
vous avez une opinion c'est peut-être
pas le moment de l'exprimer mais en tout
cas comment abordez-vous la création de
de France travail même si ça peut
paraître un peu tôt pour aborder ces
questions mais elles sont quand même
liées
à ce projet de loi si on aborde sur le
plan politique et il y a pas seulement
implant technique mais un plan politique
parce que ça concerne directement la
gouvernance à venir je vous remercie je
vous laisse répondre à ces questions
promis je l'ai pas essayé de faire plus
long mais ça méritait très peu ça
mériterait plus long
alors
sur sur si je prends l'activité
partielle pour les organisations
clairement
l'activité partielle qui est très un
dispositif très ancien en fait
et notamment au moment de la crise covid
les organisations n'ont pas n'ont pas du
tout
remis en cause le financement le
financement par lunettique en tout cas
remis en cause le dispositif ça sans
aucun doute remis en cause le
financement on était tellement dans
l'urgence que il y a même pas eu de
sujets j'ai envie de dire mais d'où
notre volonté de l'isoler de l'isoler
aujourd'hui le dispositif
alors voilà la marge on peut toujours
faire des améliorations le dispositif
fonctionne pas trop mal je mets un peu
je vous mets dans le viseur également
l'APLD donc l'activité partielle de
longue durée qui est quelque chose d'un
tout petit peu différent et qui nommant
notamment demande un accord
collectif
en général en général de branche souvent
son couverts par des accords de branches
mais aussi d'entreprise sont des accords
qui sont qui sont qui sont intéressants
et qui notamment permettent
s'ils sont bien négociés si je vais me
permettre un commentaire permettent un
petit peu de d'entrevoir
quel type d'activité d'action peut être
mise pendant l'activité partielle parce
que c'était peut-être plus délicat en
période de crise ultime comme le covid
mais le faire quand alors quand c'est
archi exceptionnel sur un temps court on
peut pas forcément le penser mais quand
c'est un petit peu plus structurel ont
été activité partielle pouvoir en
profiter pour monter en compétences on
sait que ça fait partie des enjeux
aujourd'hui
sur le sur le marché du travail je pense
que le dispositif peut être consolidé
s'il n'est pas voilà autant on arrive un
petit peu à le faire les partenaires
sociaux les entreprises et des branches
arrivent un peu à le faire dans le cadre
de l'activité partielle longue durée
dans le cadre d'accord le dispositif de
base activité partielle et est un peu
moins un peu moins incitatif en
notamment quand il s'agit de partir en
formation il y a pas de de
la rémunération n'est pas du tout
complétée c'est pas du tout incitatif
voilà je
si j'ai un petit commentaire sur
l'activité partielle
VAE j'aurais beaucoup de choses à dire
mais notamment sur le projet de loi mais
je pense que du point de vue de toute
façon c'est toujours intéressant je
pense que la question comme je disais la
question des de
côté une édique
certes on
réfléchit bien évidemment à
l'indemnisation du chômage mais mais
pour nous
l'indemnisation du chômage elle va je
vais venir sur France avail n'est pas du
tout
ne vit pas on va se clos et pour nous il
est bien évident que accompagnement et
indemnisation vont ensemble et et
l'indemnisation sera d'autant moins
longue que les personnes seront
accompagnées bien accompagnés pourront
faire des formations et retrouver
rapidement un emploi stable c'est c'est
la mécanique classique donc sur France
travail pour essayer d'aller très vite
évidemment alors c'est pas le cas c'est
pas dans ce projet de loi tout un
concertation qui est lancée
ça fera sans doute l'objet d'une plus
grande loi travail telle qu'on nous
l'avait présenté en tout cas une élite
est fortement impliquée dans la mesure
où on finance aujourd'hui 4/5 du budget
de Pôle emploi
on est très intéressé de savoir ce qui
va se passer ceci dit on en sait pas
beaucoup pour l'instant et dans les
prochains mois ça devrait ça devrait un
petit peu plus émergé mais il va y avoir
une question de gouvernance
qui transitoirement va être réglé par
une prorogation je pense de la
convention tripartite actuelle est à une
édite Pôle emploi sur 2023 mais il y a
un vrai sujet de gouvernance à venir et
qui peut-être sera intégré ou non ou en
tout cas au minimum articulé avec le
chantier de la gouvernance de
l'assurance chômage
merci sur le enfin je pense que quand
vous parliez du dispositif de chômage
partiel vous parliez du dispositif de
base mais la question qui se pose c'est
s'il devait y avoir une nouvelle crise
peut-être à cause de l'énergie et des
fermetures est-ce qu'il faut reconduire
le dispositif qui avait été retenu pour
pendant la pandémie je pense que le
dispositif il était salutaire pour notre
pays et mais la situation n'est pas
exactement la même les raisons de
fermeture ne sont pas forcément les
mêmes et en faisant attention au risque
spéculatifs sur l'énergie parce que il y
a des entreprises qui peuvent fermer
pour revendre leurs droits à Rennes
parce qu'elles gagneront plus d'argent
en fermant qu'en restant ouvert je
n'accuse personne bien sûr mais il y a
un risque réel mais néanmoins je pense
qu'il faudra viser en fonction de de la
réalité de ce chômage partiel de ce
recours au chômage partiel mais c'est
pour l'instant c'est pas je pense que
c'est pas le moment
sur la dernière sur la veilleuse et rien
de plus à dire et pardon j'ai oublié la
phrase travail en fait nous nous avons
une attente vis-à-vis de France travail
parce que lunédique a deux opérateurs
l'URSSAF pour le recouvrement et ludique
attend de l'URSSAF qu'elle recouvre
comme il faut c'est-à-dire que les
recettes soient au niveau qui est
attendu convenu et vis-à-vis de France
travail qui est notre autre opérateur on
attend deux choses que France travaille
continue à pourvoir des emplois et à
faire baisser nos charges mais surtout
ou autant c'est que France travaille
Pôle Emploi pardon oui mais je vais un
peu en avance que Pôle Emploi demain
France travail demain mais Pôle Emploi
aujourd'hui
assure le versement des allocations au
niveau qui doit être versé et à ceux qui
doivent les recevoir donc il y a une
qualité de service qui est importante
pour nous si on améliore la qualité de
service
de lunédique grâce à la France travaille
on ne peut être que pour mais c'est ça
qui importe pour nous surtout
très bien alors nous avons si collègues
je vous propose puisque
nous avons un temps compter de poser les
six questions et ensuite vous vous ferez
la réponse madame Lubin ensuite pensez
Monge mouillez fan de la reine Berck
Chassin a pour ce poli madame Lubin
merci madame la Présidente
merci madame la Présidente et Monsieur
le vice-président de lunédique on fait
les questions que je vous aurais posées
nos deux futurs rapporteurs les ont déjà
posé
et nous sommes d'accord sur les
questions
à la fin du texte on verra nous sommes
d'accord sur les questions pas sûr que
nous serons d'accord sur les réponses à
apporter mais en tout cas sur les
questions et vous avez répondu donc je
ne vais pas reposer les mêmes questions
pour entendre les mêmes réponses juste
vous dire et nous sentons bien que c'est
aussi ce que vous ressentez juste vous
dire que nous nous désapprouvons
totalement
cette reprise en main par le
gouvernement de ces questions là et la
faire annoncer du paritarisme à titre
personnel mais je pense que au moins
dans mon groupe
ça sera partagé je trouve la méthode
assez violente bon mais au-delà de cela
nous aurons l'occasion d'en discuter
justement lors de la présentation de ce
projet de loi moi j'ai une question sur
la philosophie de l'assurance chômage
au-delà de tout ça justement peut-être
pas au-delà est-ce que toute cette
est-ce que toutes ces méthodes est-ce
que la forme finalement on n'attaque pas
le fond ou n'est pas précurseur de de ce
que sera le fond à savoir est-ce qu'on
n'est pas en train de changer de
philosophie de l'assurance chômage en
étant en train finalement de réduire au
maximum l'indemnisation des demandeurs
d'emploi en étant en train de les
pousser à revenir obligatoirement vers
l'emploi et on était en train aussi de
de
comment dire non pas de susciter parce
que ça existe déjà mais finalement de
corroborer ce que dit la vox populi à
savoir où elle est chômeurs en una
ras-le-bol il faut qu'il reparte bosser
alors qu'on sait que tout ça est
beaucoup plus compliqué n'est ce pas et
donc finalement en prenant de telles
décisions on est en train de corroborer
ce que dit la box populi or la box
populi moi je pense qu'il faut souvent
l'éclairer parce qu'elle est capable de
comprendre beaucoup de choses plutôt que
de l'amener à à réfléchir de manière un
peu abrupte et à courte vue l'assurance
chômage elle est faite aussi me
semble-t-il pour que les demandeurs
d'emploi et le temps après un échec dans
l'emploi parce que perdre son emploi
c'est toujours un échec c'est vécu comme
un échec par la personne qui le qui qui
le subit est-ce que finalement on ne
revient pas sur le principe selon lequel
le demandeur d'emploi a aussi un peu de
temps un peu de temps pour retravailler
son avenir professionnel pour se former
pour changer d'orientation alors que là
on est dans l'obligation stricte de
reprendre un emploi et je dirais même
n'importe quel emploi dans n'importe
quelle condition sinon on peut se
retrouver quasiment du jour au lendemain
sans sans subside pour vivre au
quotidien donc est-ce qu'on n'est pas là
en train de changer de philosophie
Raymonde pense et mange
[Musique]
entendu public alors ma question est la
suivante pourquoi ce rapport n'a-t-il
pas encore été rendu public et que
contient-il qu'est-ce que l'on sait
aujourd'hui du non recours au droit en
matière d'assurance chômage actuellement
et pour revenir sur cette mission
d'évaluation aussi qui vous incombe à
l'assurance chômage j'aimerais savoir
enfin pardon à votre organisme si vous
prévisions sur la baisse des allocations
induites par la loi de 2018
est confirmé combien cette baisse serait
de combien combien de baisse
d'allocataires aussi parce que c'est des
allocataires aussi qui baisse
bon et
aussi est-ce que dans l'avenir je
termine vous comptez quand même par
rapport à ce qu'elle vient de dire
Madame Lubin évaluer la qualité de
l'emploi retrouvé suite à cette loi
c'est-à-dire en termes de taux de
remplacement par rapport au salaire
précédent de temps partiel de CDD ou de
du de l'emploi par est-ce que ces
salariés ne vont pas venir les
intermittents de demain entre salaires
et chômage voilà je vous remercie
merci Madame le présidente merci pour
votre présentation
madame la Présidente
et notamment pour nous éclairer sur un
certain nombre de chiffres moi j'ai bien
noté que la dette de l'inédit
qu'aujourd'hui pour un tiers de cette
dette était finalement une dette covid
et lorsqu'on parle lorsqu'on fait le
point lorsqu'on regarde le bilan du
gouvernement concernant la dette covid
souvent cette ligne n'apparaît pas et
c'est important parce que ça veut dire
que c'est une décision nationale avec
des outils existants qui fait que ça
Paque directement donc c'est bien de le
repréciser dans le contexte parce que ça
pèse directement sur votre gestion j'ai
bien entendu également votre
interrogation sur le champ
d'intervention ludique en disant notre
choix est très large puisqu'on
intervenant également pour les retraites
toute la bonne également pour Pôle
Emploi moi ma question est-ce qu'il faut
pas recentrer l'unique sur son activité
première mais en échange de quoi est-ce
que la question financement de plus de
35% par la CSG ne se met pas sur la
table en corollaire puisque je pense que
globalement le budget sécurité sociale
aura regardé bienveillant sur un apport
de 35% de de CSG donc c'est une question
de transfert qui pourrait se poser
ensuite concernant la réforme bon on a
bien compris que le jaune c'est
difficile d'évaluer la réforme restante
alors qu'on est déjà en train d’aborder
une nouvelle réforme on peut imaginer
que l'intention du gouvernement c'est
d'aller un peu plus loin soit au nombre
de mesures moi j'entends madame le
Président de vos interventions sur mon
territoire je suis entouré sur
l'entreprise qui aujourd'hui vivent en
permanence le fait de ne pas trouver de
recrues qui vivent en permanence le fait
de refus de CDI à l'issue de CDD ou de
contrats de courte durée moi ma question
à ce que je texte cela n'est pas
l'occasion de venir durcir clairement se
positionnement et deuxième point nous
savons que les ruptures conventionnelles
ont pu être un atout aujourd'hui est-ce
que les ruptures conventionnelles ne
sont pas quelque part utiliser de façon
abusive au détriment du marché de
l'emploi la vraie question c'est faut-il
pas profiter de ce texte là pour mettre
les vérités sur la table entre
aujourd'hui il est 1,5 millions
d'emplois non pourvu et les 7,4% de taux
de chômage au niveau national
bien monsieur
madame la Présidente et je voudrais
poser
une simple question sur la gouvernance
parce que je me souviens quand nous vous
avons rencontré lors de la discussion
sur la loi organique de la sécurité
sociale
vous avoir invité
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux tu
t'en souviens Catherine on était
ensemble à mettre à plat le système
paritaire
il y a une révision complète du
paritarisme dans la gestion de de
l'assurance chômage j'aurais dit si vous
voulez pas que l'État s'en mêle plus qui
ne le fait actuellement il sera obligé
d'intervenir peut revenir sur la dette
si vous voulez si vous prenez
l'engagement de l'éponger complètement
elle était quand même déjà 30 milliards
en 2017
est-ce qu'au vide l'a aggravé peut-être
mais ça ça reste donc je pense que
s'il y a pas une profonde
révision du fonctionnement de la
gouvernance et bien malheureusement le
paritarisme aura vécu je suis désolé
parce que je suis pas ritariste à fond
je dirais que j'y crois ça fonctionne
très bien la jarcone notamment on est
dans un système un peu différent il y a
du long terme là-bas vous êtes vous dans
du court terme on peut dire
mais et du contrat cyclique en plus donc
j'ai bien conscience des difficultés
mais si vous prenez pas le problème à
bras le corps c'est évident que ça
d'ailleurs depuis 2019 les choses ont
changé on a supprimé les cotisations
salariales j’étais opposé parce que ça
songeait la nature complète du régime de
l'assurance chômage ont passé un système
d'assistance
cotisez encore évidemment et les
salariés de ce fait mais
où est paritarisme
pour moi ce sont des questions de fond
et si on ne les aborde pas à travers
cette loi on les abordera jamais sauf
peut-être avec France travail vous avez
souligné à combien vous ne devez pas
fonctionner en basse flou j'en suis
totalement conscient pour moi je pense
qu'il faut dépasser complètement la
notion de chômage il faut viser le plein
emploi ça veut dire formation de tous
les de tous ceux malheureusement qui se
retrouvent un jour au chômage et être en
formation ce n'est plus être au chômage
c'est être en activité intellectuelle de
formation et de qualification et ça si
on le pose pas comme ça le problème on
arrivera jamais à trouver les solutions
voilà
alors Daniel chassaint et pour terminer
Cathy a pour sopoli Daniel merci madame
la Présidente merci monsieur le
Président de madame vous explications
donc si vous voulez
vous nous avez expliqué effectivement
que la dette d'une partie de la dette
était due à au chômage partiel
concernant pendant la période de covid
alors quels sont les déficits réels que
vous considérez du uniquement
dans l'unique est responsable et depuis
2020 n'avez-vous pas eu de réponse du
gouvernement je suppose que vous avez
questionné pour la prise en charge de
cette dette que vous considérez être
pays introdu au direct type de l'État et
donc payer par par le gouvernement
et enfin
troisième question vous avez évoqué
France travail est-ce que
dans l'avenir il faut pas avoir comme un
peu pour le RSA c'est à dire prendre en
que les chômeurs soient peut-être pris
en charge pour avoir un diagnostic sur
leur plan sur le plan de la santé du
logement
de la situation de de la mobilité et en
fonction de ce diagnostic si vous voulez
aller
après vers l'emploi c'est à dire prendre
en charge plus globalement la personne
qui est qui est au chômage
merci madame la Présidente une fois
n'est pas coutume mais je partage
l'intervention qui a fait monsieur
vanderenberg sur certains sujets le Nord
notamment
le Pas-de-Calais pas le Nord le
Pas-de-Calais monsieur van murenberg
donc sur le paritarisme mais sur aussi
la volonté d'aller vers le plein emploi
parce que je pense que l'emploi est bien
c'est aussi la dignité mais aller vers
le plein emploi évidemment pas n'importe
quelle condition avec des conditions de
travail dignes et avec des salaires
évidemment qui soient à la hauteur alors
on le voit bien dans cette réforme
l'exécutif souhaite moduler donc les
conditions de travail de l'assurance
chômage selon la situation de marché du
marché du travail à l'image finalement
de ce qui se fait au Canada à l'échelon
donc régional et donc
le projet du gouvernement semble être
d'agir donc sur la durée d'indemnisation
depuis la réforme donc de 2019 il faut
avoir travaillé
6 mois sur les 24 derniers mois pour
bénéficier mais demain est-ce que ce
sera 7 ou 8 mois ou est-ce que ce sera
six mois sur 18 au lieu de 24 mois et
puis avec cette modulation si je ne
prends qu'un exemple vous avez évoqué
madame tout à l'heure la question fort
importante des contrats courts
mais je vous pose aussi un cas concret
si par exemple une aide-soignante
épuisée parce que nous savons que c'est
difficile
arrête de travailler elle aura donc une
indemnisation sur une période moindre
car le besoin du secteur médico-social
sera fort
donc on fait un peu fille aussi il me
semble de la pénibilité de ces emplois
voilà je vous remercie
et bien donc beaucoup de questions vous
vous
en 3 minutes j'avoue que
vous mettez au défi il reste à peu près
10 minutes
donc
c'est le pari tarisme
alors j'étais en train de me demander
comment j'allais j'allais intervenir
peut-être si vous me le permettez pour
faire en cinq minutes peut-être un petit
peu globalement
plusieurs d'entre vous ont posé des
questions autour du rôle du régime et du
rôle du paritarisme je
je partage totalement nous partageons
c'est très collectif totalement l'idée
que
il y a besoin de de
refonder
alors il y a eu un accord sur le
paritarisme il y a quelques mois je le
mets un accord collectif un accord
national interpro sur le paritarisme il
y a quelques mois notamment notamment
dans dans toutes ces relations dans les
relations entre les organisations la
démocratie sociale si j'utilise des
grands mots la démocratie politique et
des éléments autour du paritarisme de
gestion ce que je veux dire c'est que on
est clairement aujourd'hui dans un dans
une situation où on a besoin de de
clarifier les choses et
plusieurs l'ont dit je pense que la
vraie au-delà de la place des
partenaires sociaux qui est un vrai
sujet en soi etc il y a une vraie
question autour du régime c'est à dire à
quoi il sert et et si on part on part de
cette question là à mon avis on peut
déjà détricoter pas mal de choses
et répondre et aider à clarifier et à
clarifier les responsabilités et
alors à quoi il sert plutôt que
ponctuellement dire bah on va ajouter
des personnes qui en ont besoin ou se
dire maintenant il y a les contrats
courts il faut
prendre en charge ou alors la pénibilité
de certaines personnes etc le régime il
peut pas tout faire soyons clairs donc
je pense qu'il y a vraiment un besoin de
clarification à quoi répond la sur le
chômage il y a très très certainement
aujourd'hui sur le marché du travail des
nouveaux besoins qui qui apparaissent et
qui ont besoin et qui ont pardon
auxquels il faut pouvoir répondre et
pouvoir répondre de manière beaucoup
sans doute beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
systémique donc le régime non seulement
ils doivent en soit s'interroger sur son
périmètre sur quoi il sert à quoi il
répond et comment il s'articule avec
d'autres systèmes de protection que ce
soit celui de la pénibilité celui de la
formation etc etc moi je pense que c'est
vraiment en partant de cette question
qu'on pourra qu'on pourra pour le coup
je vous donne plus un sentiment un
sentiment personnel
qu'on partage qu'on partage globalement
mais c'est vraiment un point un point
majeur et dans tous les cas
en ne partant pas nécessairement de de
la nature du financement je pense que ça
c'est un vrai sujet parce que on c'est
important que ça soit des cotisations
sociales ou de la CSG etc mais si on
veut refonder partons partons de
l'utilité du régime à quoi il doit
répondre à quoi et donc toute la
réflexion autour de France travail
est-ce qu'on doit s'articuler sur
l'accompagnement est-ce qu'on doit le
financer est-ce qu'il y a besoin
d'accompagnement global pour certaines
personnes n'oublions pas que aujourd'hui
on parle du chômage mais les chômeurs
sont des publics extrêmement extrêmement
hétérogènes et qui ne se ressent pas qui
ont des besoins extrêmement différents
et voilà il faut resituer sans doute
l'indemnisation dans l'ensemble de cet
écosystème là et sans doute pas alors ça
c'est encore plus personnel je vais le
dire en tout cas de mon organisation ne
pas le mélanger avec les minimals
sociaux qu'on soit très clair voilà
mais je partage cette volonté du besoin
l'autre thème sur lequel vous êtes vous
êtes intervenu il me semble touche
beaucoup aux questions d'évaluation
en général
que ce soit sur le non recours pour le
coup nous n'avons pas plus
d'informations que vous sur ce rapport
donc voilà je ne veux pas vous en dire
plus je pense que vous interrogerez qui
de droit sur sur le sur le sujet que ce
soit sur sur
l'ensemble des l'ensemble des règles qui
peuvent qui peuvent être qui ont pu être
mises en place ça me semble ça me semble
extrêmement important ou éclairer le
débat public
éclairé le débat public sur sur des
prochaines sur des prochaines réformes
vous vous avez pardon
parler de la durée d'indemnisation et
une concertation qui va qui va
arriver sur ce thème là a priori
clairement on va faire
on va faire quelques règles de trois
avec quelques hypothèses sur les
indicateurs dont on entend parler dans
la presse pour l'instant pour essayer de
voir de voir ce que ça donne quand on
veut évaluer une réforme notamment quand
elle doit être incitative
modifier les comportements c'est clair
que ça se fait pas en trois mois donc en
termes de rigueur d'analyse
on va être très on va être très prudent
ceci dit ceci dit dans tous les cas
chaque fois l'unedique fait des
évaluations sur les anciennes réformes
et et
donne des éléments de réflexion aux
partenaires sociaux et au débat public
sur les nouvelles chaque fois sous deux
angles ça je suis à la fois sous sa
dimension financière et à la fois sur
les impacts pour les pour les personnes
c'est vraiment un axe extrêmement fort
qu'on veut pouvoir
et j'ai juste un dernier petit chiffre
monsieur sur les emplois vacants je
pense qu'on n'est pas un million cinq en
tout cas ce sont pas les chiffres de la
statistique publique pour le coup voilà
donc non l'adresse vient de je sais que
c'est très compliqué d'identifier
d'identifier ce qui est un emploi vacant
une offre d'emploi etc mais la DARES a
sorti des derniers chiffres en haut
certes mais on est en gros entre 350 500
000 on n'est pas du tout à la hauteur du
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
aujourd'hui et ça reste très très
compliqué pour certains publics de
retourner à l'emploi voilà
merci
je vais je vais être très prétentieux et
vous dire que je vais tenter de répondre
à toutes les questions en même temps
mais il y a un lien quand même ça tombe
bien
je pense comme l'a dit Patricia il y a
pas un chômage il y a des chômage on
pourrait s'appeler l'assurance chômage
au pluriel mais il a des questions de
philosophie et je pense peut-être à la
différence de Patricia qui a plutôt mis
relativiser c'est l'importance de la
source de financement en fait la bascule
pour moi elle a eu lieu lorsqu'on a
remplacé les cotisations salariales par
la CSG parce que c'est ça qui a changé
la philosophie
ça a changé la philosophie parce que
on était pleinement dans un système
assurantiel enfin pleinement
principalement et
ça impacte sur la perception de du
demandeur d'emploi lui-même c'est-à-dire
quand tant que c'est une assurance
on rembourse des sinistres et c'est un
accident de la vie c'est ça laisse
entendre que c'est une aide transitoire
etc quand ça devient quand on passe à un
système de financement au titre de la
solidarité nationale on fait d'une
modeur d'emploi presque pour certains en
tout cas on fait de la demande d'emploi
un statut et c'est en ce sens que la
philosophie change
et du coup
la bascule ayant été faite qu'est-ce que
l'on fait dans une situation où dans
certains départements on arrive à du
plein emploi et le travail de Pôle
emploi n'est pas le même partout en
Vendée d'où je suis dans une partie de
la Vendée en tout cas
Pôle emploi aide les entreprises à
recruter dans d'autres
territoires Pôle Emploi accompagne
complètement les demandeurs d'emploi et
dans les deux demandeurs d'emploi comme
on le disait il y a deux il y a
plusieurs catégories il y a ceux qui ont
un accident transitoire qui sont entre
deux emplois il n'y a pas besoin de les
accompagner dans leur recherche d'emploi
ils se débrouillons tout seul
il y en a d'autres pour lesquelles c'est
un peu plus compliqué il faut les former
pour les réorienter vers de nouveaux
emplois sa pôle emploi le fait plutôt
assez bien avec l'aide des régions et
puis il y a ceux qui sont in employables
et j'aime pas tellement le terme mais
par contre c'est une réalité et pendant
20 ans j'ai présidé une association en
insertion par le logement ce sont des
populations que j'ai rencontrées et il y
a pas il y a pas de solution pour elle
si on n'a pas une approche par
l'inclusion de ces personnes là
c'est-à-dire l'insertion dans toutes les
dimensions de leur de leur vie que ce
soit le travail la santé je dis la santé
parce que dans ces populations que je
connais un peu il y en a beaucoup qui
relèvent de la psychiatrie et ça la
société l'oublie ne veut pas le voir et
pour cela moi je ne sais pas ce que Pôle
emploi peut faire en l'état et peut-être
que France travaille alors il se trouve
que Thibault de guy-lui le préfigruateur
vient de ce monde du social et peut-être
qu'il aura comme les passions de voir
comment on peut accompagner cette
demande cette population particulière
pour lequel il n'y a pas une solution il
y a un dispositif à mettre en place moi
c'est ce que j'espère personnellement
avec France travail mais en tout cas je
suis d'accord pour dire la philosophie a
changé alors est-ce qu'on adapte la
gouvernance à la nouvelle philosophie où
on revient à la philosophie
d'origine c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure en commençant c'est pas à moi de
trancher simplement sur la préoccupation
autour de la gouvernance je pense qu'on
en est tous conscient tous les
partenaires sociaux qui a quelque chose
qui peut se jouer en ce moment
simplement si ça peut rassurer les
partisans du paritarisme le
monorganisation notamment je foire route
Bézieux m'a demandé de prendre ce mandat
non pas pour m'occuper des finances de
l'unédique mais pour défendre le
paritarisme au sein de lunédique
peut-être que ça n'apparaissait pas
évident à certains mais en tout cas ou
alors il m'a vendu un truc pour me
convaincre mais mais il y a peut-être eu
un doute mais moi je j'en ai reparlé
avec lui c'est vraiment enfin il a
réitéré sa demande
j'en suis parfaitement content merci
nous aussi
très bien
regarde si
la personne que nous devons additionner
arriver auquel cas ça allait
si vous avez vous avez encore deux
minutes si vous avez des points à
rajouter
c'est terminé c'est terminé
si vous aviez voulu préciser un point
particulier
si je peux me permettre madame la
Présidente bon je dis ce que j'ai
entendu me convient parfaitement à
condition effectivement que lunédique se
saisisse réellement de cette question du
paritarisme sinon je veux dire la
machine est en route pour que ça vous
échappe complètement
et je pense que que ce soit France
travail sous sa nouvelle Pôle emploi
sous cette nouvelle forme ou s'il y a
pas les partenaires sociaux au premier
plan au premier rang ça marchera pas je
veux dire il faut qu'il y ait
et il faut même j'ai entendu que dans
France travail on allait associer aussi
tous les les associations qui font de
l'inclusion moi je présidais pendant
plus de 20 ans
une association qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui Maison de l'Emploi et des
métiers c'était à l'origine la maison
des chômeurs mais on a complètement
changer je dirais de paradigme on s'est
dit il faut travailler maintenant sur
l'insertion et par tous les moyens
est évident que vous posez un vrai
problème qui se pose qui va se poser à
l'assurance maladie c'est de savoir si
ce que l'on fait des gens qui sont
malheureusement in employables j'aime
pas ce terme
mais qui ont des difficultés de santé
sous différentes très différentes dans
certains pays je pense au Pays-Bas ont
on les on les retire du chômage
c'est un problème social qu'il faut
traiter parce que je pense je pense
qu'il doit on doit changer la
philosophie et se dire que quand on est
aux portes du plein emploi il faut
permettre à tout le monde d'avoir sa
chance et donc on peut avoir une un
accident on est en arrêt si vous voulez
mais on est en arrêt sur image on a
encore la possibilité de se réintégrer
si on se forme
et donc pour ça tout doit être pris dans
cet ensemble dans cette vision
d'ensemble et vous avez un rôle
important imminent parce que vous avez
aussi une trentaine 35 milliards de
cotisations
donc de moyens enfin pas de ce monde
cotisation et de contribution aussi
merci merci beaucoup merci et puis si
vous voulez compléter des rapporteurs
vous contacteront exactement merci bien
bonne fin de journée bon courage